[Musique]
comme tous les mardis Ludivine fait ses
courses cette mère de deux enfants vient
dans ce supermarché une fois par semaine
pour remplir son frigo elle consacre en
moyenne 300 euros à son budget
alimentaire
pour s'y retrouver dans les rayons pas
de liste de courses
Ludivine dégaine son smartphone
en plus des promotions traditionnelles
proposées par son supermarché elle a
repéré sur son téléphone des réductions
qui ne sont pas affichées en magasin
c'est prendre celui-ci produit je vais
regarder si il se trouve en rayon parce
que c'est celui que je voulais acheter
là je le vois pas
non il est pas là il doit être spécial
ou dans l'autre rayon de l'autre côté au
bio
faire les courses prend alors des
allures de chasse au trésor
et donc le voici et c'est celui-ci que
je vais scanner pour vérifier si c'est
bien le produit effectivement c'est bien
le bon produit donc c'est bien celui-ci
que je vais prendre
adeptes des applications depuis 10 ans
Ludivine maîtrise son sujet
donc ces trois produits coûtent à
l'origine 5,97 moi l'application va me
rembourser donc 2 euros pour l'achat de
3 et comme il y a les petits bons de
réduction qui se trouve dessus les les
produits unitaires il y a 40 centimes
donc s'il reviendra une fois tout déduit
à deux euros 77
elle jongle à la perfection entre les
bons de réduction et les applications
j'en ai trois j'ai fini je suis au pire
mes petits et donc ça permet de faire
quand même quelques économies sur le
mois
pas question de changer les habitudes
alimentaires du foyer pour ces demandes
de remboursement
prendre des produits sans promotion ça
nous arrivera rarement à la maison là
effectivement c'est que le beurre c'est
plus
qui gagne mais comme il a pas de promo
bah on prend c'est pas grave on prend
quand même le produit
[Musique]
une fois les réductions cumulées
Ludivine réalise sur ses courses une
économie de 26%
de retour à la maison le travail n'est
pas terminé il faut demander les
remboursements pour chaque produit
qui viennent compléter son revenu à
temps partiel
donc pour ce produit là-dedans est
envoyé
c'est aussi la crise pour les
applications de bons plans il y a 5 ans
Ludivine économiser 100 euros de plus
par mois mais une nouvelle loi restreint
désormais les promotions sur
l'alimentation
effectivement les applications par
rapport à avancent sont moins
intéressants du fait effectivement de la
loi Macron qui interdit aujourd'hui en
tout cas sur l'alimentation du 100%
remboursé donc ce qui fait que les
applications sont contraintes elles de
rembourser que un certain pourcentage
maximum avec la loi
Ludivine cumule d'autres types
d'applications pour pallier le manque à
gagner
[Musique]
j'utilise les applications
anti-gaspiques comme Phoenix
pour économiser ça permet aussi de
réduire bien le budget
[Musique]
Phoenix c'est justement l'application
qu'utilise Alexandre ce commercial a
installé la plateforme anti-gaspi il y a
quatre ans sur son téléphone son budget
alimentation s'élève à 500 euros par
mois pour une famille de quatre
personnes
après sa journée de travail Alexandre
parcours son smartphone
j'ai ici les commerçants qui ont qui ont
l'habitude ou qui affichent des paniers
autour de moi je cherche le commerçant
chez qui je souhaite retirer un panier
donc aujourd'hui moi j'ai prévu de
commander un panier chez le primeur
thivo sous les halles de Tours
et il fait une remise de 5 euros donc il
est vendu 5 euros aujourd'hui sur
l'application il faut aller vite car les
paniers anti gaspi partent rapidement
salut environ une fois par semaine je me
rends chez les commerçants aux environs
pour aller retirer soit des fruits et
légumes ici soit des produits de
boulangerie il peut même m'arriver des
fois d'aller chercher les restes d'un
restaurant des invendus du Midi
et voilà
[Musique]
bonjour je vais retirer mon panier
Phoenix
et voilà super
salade il y a du raisin il y a des
pommes des poires il y a des poivrons il
y a un concombre il y a des tomates j'ai
cette diversifier les paniers un petit
peu
voilà j'essaie de mettre un petit peu de
tout que les gens découvrent un petit
peu et puis ça évite que les produits
partent à la poubelle les paniers de ce
primeurs ont du succès près de 4000
personnes suivent ce commerce sur
l'application Phoenix
Alexandre ne savait pas à l'avance ce
que contiendrait le sien ce qui ne
l'empêche pas d'être déjà très inspiré
[Musique]
soit en fait on va faire des pizzas
qu'on va agrémenter avec le poivron et
on va pouvoir prendre une salade avec
une ou deux salades avec on va les
éplucher et après les pommes on va
pouvoir les consommer plus tard ça je
dirais que c'est un panier qui fait 3 4
jours facilement à la maison en fait on
peut dire que sur un mois c'est
facilement 30 à 50 euros d'économiser
avec les paniers phœnix si on achète
environ un ou deux paniers par semaine
avec 5 euros de gains sur chaque panier
on évite on trouve vite notre compte
[Musique]
termine ses études pour devenir
éducatrice spécialisée joindre les deux
bouts n'est pas toujours facile pour
cette étudiante
elle ne consacre pourtant que 10 euros à
son ameublement grâce à une application
de dons d'objets
[Musique]
et bien du coup c'est un blender et je
l'ai dénicher sur give du coup si il est
gratuit tout neuf
et le voilà je suis trop contente
waouh des dons Kathleen on a plein ces
placards
tous ces bocaux de pâtes j'ai eu toutes
ces poils du coup pour essayer dans le
thème des fans également
toute ma vaisselle
donc il y a beaucoup de vaisselle pour
une étudiante et au salon la liste
d'objets récupérés s'allonge il y a ce
meuble et cette bibliothèque avec
tous les livres que vous voyez là de
give donc on a des livres de cuisine qui
va le quand même extrêmement cher et
puis des livres aussi du coup pour pour
mes études qui veulent encore plus cher
des objets avec des défauts comme ce
canapé usé déniché sur l'application
mais qui lui ont permis de se meubler
alors qu'elle était sans revenue
[Musique]
n'étant pas accepté au Secours populaire
ni au Resto du Coeur c'était give m'a
seule solution alors j'ai bénéficié de
donc pendant plusieurs mois et ça m'a
vraiment sauvé
pour trouver ces nombreux dons c'est sur
son téléphone que tout se passe
l'application propose des objets ou
encore de la nourriture
après avoir beaucoup reçu la jeune femme
fait elle aussi des dons sur la
plateforme
malgré que je sois étudiante je m'en
sers je m'en sors un petit peu plus
financièrement aujourd'hui et je suis
toujours dans cette démarche de de
pouvoir donner dès que j'ai la
possibilité parce que je me dis on sait
pas de quoi est fait demain et peut-être
que demain justement je vais me
retrouver justement dans dans cette
précarité donc c'est vraiment toujours
un plaisir de donner
[Musique]
faire du lèche vitrine une passion pour
Camille véritable choppeuse addict elle
consacre en moyenne 300 euros par mois à
son budget habillement mais depuis
quelques années son téléphone bouscule
ses habitudes de consommation
[Musique]
allez dans les boutiques je le fais de
moins en moins j'essaye vraiment
d'acheter sur vinted donc ces derniers
temps oui je peux dire que j'y vais même
plus une fois par mois
cette petite révolution s'opère dans son
appartement Camille gagne chaque mois un
peu d'argent grâce aux vêtements qu'elle
ne porte pas
du coup on commence toujours par une
jolie photo bien à plat où on voit le
vêtement en entier faut que ça donne
envie donc je le mets toujours sur un
fond neutre et j'essaye d'en faire en
sorte qu'il est pas trop de plis qu'il
est pas l'air d'avoir été porté que il
paraissent tout propre tout neuf et qui
l'inspire confiance déjà je fais une
photo en grande vue et faire la même de
l'autre côté pour bien montrer tous les
aspects et prouver qu'il a pas de défaut
donc là pareil hop le dos vous êtes
juste mettre l'étiquette avec la taille
à l'intérieur
et en trois photos c'est fait ces trois
photos suffisent pour transformer ce
short en monnaie sonante et trébuchante
j'ai dû porter deux fois que c'était pas
super confortable pour moi autant le
revendre
dans son dressing virtuel camille a une
vingtaine d'articles ce polo a manches
longues a trouvé preneuse elle l'a vendu
10 euros
en short ou un t-shirt ça peut partir en
deux jours après des plus gros articles
comme des baskets ou des vestes ça va
mettre une petite semaine mais
généralement c'est des trucs que je suis
sûr de vendre
en 2021 on est à 335 euros 20
sur plus en 2022 je suis sûr d'avoir au
bon Dieu beaucoup plus
avec ses ventes camille a pu s'offrir
une folie
une paire de bottes qu'elle n'aurait pas
pu s'offrir neuve du coup elles sont
affichés à 450 euros sur le site Chloé
et là je les ai eu du coup neuves sur
vinted à 140 euros donc c'est vraiment
une super affaire oui je suis très
contente
[Musique]
Vincent est indépendant il est en
déplacement professionnel une à deux
fois par semaine des trajets qui pèsent
lourd sur son budget il consacre en
moyenne 200 euros chaque mois rien que
pour le carburant alors Vincent
covoiture
ça fait effectivement 10 ans que
j'utilise blablacar au départ
j'utilisais beaucoup sur les trajets
gérés pour aller en vacances là depuis
peu je me suis
décidé à aller plutôt sur sur
l'application aussi pour des des petits
trajets finalement il y a sans doute des
gens qui ont la contrainte la même
contrainte que moi et qui souhaiterait
pouvoir faire ce trajet bon et bien
voilà on est arrivé du coup merci à plus
et à bientôt au revoir
le covoiturage domicile travaille doit
se démocratiser 70% de ses trajets se
font encore son passager
moi sur le l'aller-retour bourg-
Châteauroux j'ai que une personne au
retour j'ai personnalisé voilà après il
faut aussi que les horaires collent
c'est toujours c'est toujours une
question de d'offre et de demande
finalement
planète comme pour les autres
utilisateurs d'applications Vincent et
trouve son compte
ça peut être intéressant ça me fait un
plein sur le mois quoi donc c'est quand
même intéressant disons que mon prix de
l'essence comme dirait blablacar ils ont
une une bannière en ce moment qui dit ça
il est peut-être à 50 centimes le litre
au lieu d'être à 1,60 70 aujourd'hui
quoi
d'ici 2024 le gouvernement vise 3
millions de trajets quotidiens en
covoiturage une prime métal étude pour
les nouveaux utilisateurs
[Musique]
vendre ses vêtements proposer une place
dans sa voiture se faire rembourser une
partie de ses courses collecter des
paniers anti-gaspi notre salut face à
cette inflation galopante serait-il dans
notre téléphone
deux tiers des Français ont d'ores et
déjà modifié leurs habitudes de
consommation
[Musique]